is singing and being in a band
nerve-racking i mean is it a constant
test about how good you are it's
terrifying every day is it every single
time and my heart is in my throat right
now you know it's just it's terrifying
every day and it's awesome is it awesome
or is there a love-hate relationship
with it like sometimes you go [ __ ] why
am i doing this i mean yeah the
adrenaline spikes are pretty pretty
intense you're always risking total
humiliation every time you open your
mouth you're a self-taught musician in
other words you didn't have music
lessons did you no no really so how do
you was you your mom was a country
singer yeah my mom's my mom was a
country singer in like bar bands and
line dancing bands and stuff like that
yeah and would you go to bars when you
were a little kid and watch her perform
i grew up in bars i spent so much time
in bars and eagles clubs and elks lodges
and singing karaoke and singing with
bands and line dancing and stuff was
your mom frustrated that she never hit
the big time or was she a frustrated
artist or satisfied with her career
super satisfied she's one of those
people that was just
lived just to sing and smile and kind of
like tap her foot on stage and entertain
people it didn't really matter if there
was 10 people there or 500 people there
it didn't seem like any difference for
her so if you got up at the bar and sang
a song when you were little i don't when
did you start going to bars something
like eight years old right yeah like my
first time ever singing on stage uh was
i was like seven
and what gives you that courage is it
all the positive feedback you get from
your mama she's is it like that's a way
to win or love
um she definitely gave me a lot of
positive feedback and my brother um
in in our singing we started singing
really young and she was into singing
and when her dad died he had lou
gehrig's disease it was kind of a
rebirth for her he died super young like
49 50 years old so um it was like this
rebirth for her and and you know we her
mom used some of the money that her dad
left to buy like a pa system and my mom
put bands together and that was how we
got our joy is it hard for your mom to
see your success in in the sense that
maybe she's like [ __ ] i should i should
have had a record deal i should have
been able to do this no she loves it and
she loves she loved the level she was at
she would never wanted to do this job oh
my goodness she would have never wanted
to do this job and you go up on stage
for the first time what did you sing i
sing tennessee flat top box by roseanne
cash actually johnny cash wrote it but
roseanne cass performed it
and i just remember that like i was
already so confident and like full of
myself that i was positive that like my
40 year old guitar player was going to
mess it up but that i was going to be
perfect you yelled at him yeah i was
just like hey [ __ ]
why don't you get this right
are you good does the crowd like go
berserk for you i mean there was like
300 people there it was a northwest
grand ole opry and i just remember
hearing the applause for the first time
and that was it you were addicted yeah